son cientos las personas que siguen
dirigiéndose a la frontera de belarús
con polonia ya su llegada el panorama es
desesperanzador les esperan las tropas
polacas y la valla de alambre de púas
medidas de contención que el gobierno
polaco pretende reforzar si es necesario
si el número de emigrantes ilegales
crece añadiremos más soldados como digo
ahora mismo la frontera está protegida
el paso fronterizo está cerrado como he
recalcado todo el tiempo y lo cuida en
la guardia de fronteras el ejército y la
policía grave
orbitz aunque el acceso a periodistas se
ha restringido con la declaración del
estado de emergencia en polonia el
ejecutivo asegura que hasta el momento
hay entre 3.500 y 4.000 personas paradas
en sus bosques enfrentando frías
temperaturas una crisis migratoria que
ha enfadado a la unión europea que
señala al régimen de lukashenko por usar
a los migrantes como arma política y que
ya ha anunciado un nuevo paquete de
sanciones en su contra
de ser lícito hemos informado a las
compañías aéreas de que prepararemos una
ley que sancione a aquellas que
contribuyen al tráfico de personas por
lo que y esto es bueno y lo correcto
turkish airlines ha dicho que dejará de
prestar servicios hablar holandesas
camps y flick nicmer pero a gusto
mientras los migrantes son los grandes
damnificados hasta el momento se han
contabilizado al menos 10 muertos y
muchos están en el limbo las
organizaciones humanitarias desplegadas
en la zona advierten que la situación
está empeorando con la llegada del
invierno